yeah they didn't understand that that
Riley was an original name I call you
yeah thank you
um I've had a million stories because
they they please just I'll forget them
because I have PTSD then I was said
something to make me remember something
in them I can't put the chronological
order I can't remember when they happen
I just know that this would happen when
I was young I can't remember where the
where the hotel is that her anyway was
up I was working in a dance club and I
was living in one of those hotels were
nobody talks you know everything's
nothing's seen as he's heard and next
door to me was this this this man and
his two children when was he said
seventeen
I doubt it and the other was six and she
goes there she goes
mmm he was one of these men that was
like hey that slurpy jheri curl with all
the juicy dripping gold keys in the
mouth and he was a pill cuz he kept
trying to get at me and I'd be like you
know kind of a hostile guy
and then one day I was getting off the
elevator
and many of them said I have have a
molestation issues I don't have it it's
not my I'm able to just let things pass
by when I see other children or kids
things happen to them so I got this
elevator and I stepped off and there was
nobody left away and I said and at the
exit of the elevator but then I heard it
like crying and I turned around and back
in the day that was kind of trash can
sir they were kind of a dome and the top
was like a little ashtray and and I
looked behind it and there's this little
girl who's teachers for my neighbors and
she's crying and she has blood all in
her her she's a short time and I said
what happened
and she said no and I spew you already
over he goes you get her oh no they're
gonna be so mad because I I made this
the trick man and my brain just snapped
made a tree man trick it bad she made
the chick there the trick he had tempt
her out to somebody and he had had anal
sex with her and she was bleeding yeah
she shall go
did you want me to can somebody fill me
to call your mother
no she'll just sell me back side you go
to my room and I was coming from I had
guns this my friend a new tanning salon
Beverly Hills with high pressure beds
and I got a really crispy work and so I
just stopped by story and they had this
say like this I'd never seen before
green rubbing alcohol you know and I
would use it to put my bath water take
the sting out of the December and I
bought a case he was like 39 cents a
bottle
oh yeah so I bought a box of it and I
took his old girl in my room with a tie
I try to clean up my bathroom you know
when I tried to talk about cobbler she
was damaged goods she was she was she
was just you know six years old I mean
how do you I mean I know I know I was
there before so I just knew I could let
the net have her back
he came later on he pounds on my door a
neighborhood see me take her into my
room and I filled up a bucket with that
rubbing alcohol and when he pounded on
that door I knew he was in coming there
to take that little girl for me
so I sue that bucket of rubbing alcohol
and I lit it and he was wearing
everybody's wearing a green blue my
jogging ski when they first started
coming out and he ran down this hallway
operator and he was all these big bright
green flames and then his hair was
flopping off he's dead because he was on
fire right now I put a little girl in
the hallway and I said he will never
hurt you again you see he will never
hurt you again and I pulled it back to
the in the room and shut the door and I
basically I told him that there was a
base of the hallway because he was one
of those hotels where we tried to reach
news thankfully she had it somehow I
found how to get hold of this auntie and
when I called she she she was just
ecstatic that I'd call but I said she
said that soon she had the money she
with him she'd said to me to send her to
send the bad guy so we're about to take
I got to take
you just have to promise me that you
will take care of her because she's but
yeah she knows that he'll never come in
her I don't even know what happened that
man I don't really care anybody
ambulance I don't know I don't know I
don't care you know pit up I know that
she's okay
her Anthony we still have to get her
back she told me that her mother we
never touched her yeah ever mother
Eventide she she said she would kill her
kids a little girl I don't know she know
he wasn't his mother and bad back in the
Midwestern place had both of the girls
were super scissors and I'm he took him
both she gave me some money yeah he gave
them to somebody and she took the two
little girls the mind the older ones she
liked being there I guess or something
or just kind of like you know that
syndrome where you kidnapping you knew
yeah she stayed she it was she was in
Detroit and I send her back to Detroit
yeah because I couldn't keep like
I wasn't am i capable via my dad you
know there's certain people that are
gonna be mothers who said you said you
know I try but I just I knew that I did
what I was supposed to do that was I was
- I was just a saver
I just used to get her away from there
and then passed on to me who would be
good at everybody your child I can't
think of any other way I could have done
that yeah I just was like yeah she's
just she might I need to tell you that
that was running up always in my hand i
mister stammers this man's not gonna get
this little girl whatever I ask you this
mess I could get a super bro if he said
you know he probably wearing the same
keep green jogging suit still probably
burying it yeah yeah it made me feel a
lot better when I grew Anna Brenda but
she she started crying
did you see right there finally
somebody's doctor if I go there's a
difference maybe oh why is it look good
cry people you know pleasure triggers
might I have a trigger where when I
start to quiet people are still doing
something that's really bothering me see
that's a perpetrator they know that it
Bobby whatever it is you're doing
bothers you annoys you it makes you feel
uncomfortable but they keep it for their
own gratification
that's the perpetrator there's low
levels of that and there's you know the
extreme ice cube why do they keep doing
that crying yeah it made me feel yeah
[Music]
absolutely no I can't think of anything
I couldn't have problems with myself if
I hadn't done that there was no I wasn't
an option not doing something that
wasn't obviously just I had to do
whatever they keeps me as you seem to be
the only thing I can think of because
it's this man but if I open that door
and done something that I would have
taken that job no matter what you had to
give me keys we were just kissing you
know come on hey yeah my feet when I
come back yeah thank you
say bye say bye spots I'm an auntie I
always babysit people does and I could
give auntie